Yoji Borov chuck is still drawn to the
gates of the former gdansk shipyard as a
22 year old he worked closely with leg
valenza to organize the strikes that
ultimately force the Communists to
negotiate colleague of toshiba the true
back then I'd selected two bearded
colleagues who looked like cuban
revolutionaries they came for Lent cell
on their shoulders to the gate and
helped him up on the carbs for you
bought a car two people brown people
shouted get let up get up oh no TV shows
alejado gorilla had a guru football
chuck these are unforgettable memories
of Oh enca as the strong world-renowned
labor activist who stood up to the
Communists and won a Nobel Peace Prize
but there have long been rumors that he
was a government spy in the early 1970s
now a letter of intent has surfaced that
supposedly confirms this signed by
Valenza codenamed bullock and receipts
have emerged but boruff truck touts
their authenticity he says Valenza only
talked to the communist capitalist
Covey's valances or such there was a
captain who implored valensa to ensure
no blood would be spilled bonds girl or
kind of chilly you know that's how it
started famosa never denounced anyone
and never accepted money for working
with the government I'm sure of it they
were stunned / 30 memorial plaques
commemorate the opposition members and
their fight for freedom to this day bar
of chuck is still friends with Valenza
and still admires him
you build knows they'll see buddy was
the most dynamic out of all of us he was
a leader with charisma I can you know
him yup poor chuck is following the
allegations being made against Valenza
when they emerged Valenza was touring
latin in north america giving talks his
blog documents the glamorous receptions
as well as his denial of the accusations
and his first interview we have you been
there's an apology boy I never worked as
a spy I never accepted any money being
these are the facts bar of chuck visits
the Solidarity trade union museum he
still believes in Valenza and hopes he
will weather the attacks to bar of
chocolate counts is what for once it
achieved
I'll absolutely pink Latinos with
beautiful days in august 1980 Poland was
free hope you are one thanks to let fine
says leadership no blood was spilled
negotiations made it clear that we've
one big family that reduced attentions
new beliefs rear shifted attacks tiny he
recalls how everything seemed promising
at first in 1989 valensa had negotiated
with the Communists as did the coach in
ski twins here lakpha chin ski is seen
with a moustache for Wednesday in the
kitchen skis became enemies when Valenza
was accused of spying left kuchenski
quickly accepted as true his brother
jaroslav korchinsky leading the
conservative pis party marshaled these
accusations to discredit the entire
democratic transition well Chuck says it
was a deliberate campaign and so a
recent demonstration for civil liberties
morphed into a provo when sorrelli spy
or no spy
china it's warm right now about you but
someone else wants to be the hero that
up years ago p Oregon tar chick
published a book accusing valensa of
having been an informant he feels
vindicated now that the new documents
have surfaced even though their
authenticity is disputed rondo home
business media Hardman to insecticides
back then we together critics of wanza
were decried as evil liars and vermin
those were hard times para salud but
despite this he's still disappointed by
how the accusations are being
instrumentalized politically Sonia
Hamelin it's not all right to deny about
when says leading role back then and to
pretend he worked for the Secret Service
and the Communists all his life there's
no evidence for this as the leader of
solidarity he was independent the one of
materiality ERG bar of Chuck approaches
ville winces old electrical workshop bar
of Chuck has vowed to fight forever
winces honor and for the honor of those
who fought along with solidarity for of
chacas serkan valensa will be remembered
as a liberator and for nothing else